arles entre le saucisson et la photo les
18e rencontres d'arles de la photo ont
commencé il ya quelques jours elles se
poursuivront durant le mois de juillet
la mode le portrait le reportage la
photo d'art tout ce qui fait l'univers
de la photo est représenté dans la cité
romaine jean jacques dufour clic clac
premier contact pour l'équipe d'antenne
2 avec les rencontres photographiques
d'arles obligatoire photographies
d'identité pour l'accréditation presse
deuxième passage obligé de ce festival
l'ancienne place des hommes
c'est là que tout le monde se retrouvent
pour échanger clichés et impressions
personnage du microcosme photographique
yvette 3 pouces depuis 1933 elle officie
en amateur c'est à dire avec amour
gloire au programme montre et surtout
leurs travaux il ya des personnes qui
n'ont pas la possibilité peut être
d'augmenter leurs travaux ici viennent
pour montrer ce qu'ils font avoir les
avis des conseillers quelques photos du
pet de cette place les passionnés se
rendent vers les multiples expositions
disséminées dans la ville
nous avons choisi celle de brian griffin
notamment parce qu'elle était située
dans un train amarré devant le théâtre
antique un cadre original pour une expo
de photos de célébrités britanniques
le tout en noir et blanc
le noir et blanc ce que je préfère cela
donne aux gens l'occasion de rêver parra
qui noie pas trop d'informations avec le
noir et blanc ils peuvent redécouvrir
les photos mais sur les statistiques du
festival chef c'est avant tout l'année
dernière 14 mille visiteurs en plus de
familles cette année dont 400 stagiaires
feront des stages à la fois de mode
depuis cité de reportages glaciologie et
puis il y a également six spectacles au
théâtre antique sont chacun une
production 35 d'exposition dans la ville
et plus de près d'un millier de
photographes présents dans les rues sur
la place du forum à suivant partout de
rares indispensables les quelques
données économiques du marché de la
photo
le marché global de l'appareil photo
représente un peu près un peu moins de 2
millions d'appareils vendus par an et
qu'il y as en ordre de marche en france
aujourd'hui environ 15 millions et demi
d'appareils photo en est à fonctionner
et vous me disiez le nombre de pays
qu'ils vendu à l'année dernière
115 millions enfin et cela juste pour le
plaisir
un petit tour du côté du stage animé par
jean-françois bord et sur le thème de la
photo de mode en confidence je peux vous
dire que le modèle a donné envie à toute
l'équipe d'antenne 2 de changer de
boulot et lance à la main droite
oui
c'est bien